pour le moment chacun donne sa version
des faits il va donc être très difficile
d'avoir des réponses de distinguer le
vrai du faux la France qui préside cette
réunion a déjà mise en garde contre la
campagne de désinformation de Moscou le
kéorsé qui dit avoir pris l'habitude de
voir la Russie mentir surtout dans le
contexte de la guerre en Ukraine alors
en début de réunion l'ambassadeur russe
affirme sans preuve que Moscou aurait
informé l'armée ukrainienne du transport
de ses pris Pronier et qu'un radar russe
aurait détecté deux missilees lancé
depuis carkive le territoire ukrainien
l'ambassadeur russe qui a commenté pour
des raisons inexplicables ils ont décidé
d'éliminer les leurs de son côté keV n'a
pas démenti avoir visé l'appareil mais
affirme que les Russes ne les auraient
pas prévenus du transport de ses
prisonniers de guerre ros-marie Di Carlo
la chef des affaires politiques de l'ONU
présente à la réunion qui a ouvert la
réunion n'a pas apporté d'éléments
nouveaux mais elle s'est dit inquiète du
sort des prisonniers politiqu je cite
leur destin ne doit pas être
instrumentalisé alors Kiev a demandé à
l'ONU d'inspecter le site du crash mais
là encore il sera difficile de récter de
récolter des réponses sur le territoire
russe